oui je suis soit s'apprend comme tout le
monde tous les jours et vous en avez
peur ah non mais mais quand j'y pense
oui un peu quand même pour la
confidentialité et ses enfants on sait
jamais mais il n'y a pas d'autre choix
tout le monde utilise ton fils le
problème c'est que ben il faut qu'ils
aient tout le monde autour qu'il utilise
le même pour pouvoir communiquer et
what's up c'est quand même utilisé
massivement par tout le monde donc j'ai
des amis que tu ce télégramme jeu les
télécharger mais finalement voilà il
faut que tout le monde qui soit pour
pour avoir la même qualité de
communication
will est déjà entendu parler j'ai des
connaissances eux qui ont été
désinstaller whatsapp moi j'ai vécu un
an en chine donc on a eu notre
philosophie
on a des habitués donc 6ème
personnellement je suis passé un peu
sûre signal et mais j'ai pas tout mais
groupes qui sont passés donc c'est que
quelques-uns presse continuait de ces
votes ça avec les gens qui utilisent
encore j'utilise watts a beaucoup et je
mets j'ai vu qu'elle est un des
polémiques autour de whatsapp mais qui
avait pas d'autres messageries tellement
plus sécurisé et donc finalement je
retiens à utiliser ça n'a pas posé plus
de questions ça en fait j'utilise plus
haut à de sap en fait parce que je
trouve qu'il ya trop d'applications en
fait ça il ya instagram whatsapp tik tok
je trouve qu'il ya un surplus
d'application et c'est vrai que là il y
en a trop en fait oui c utilise whatsapp
j'ai entendu parler du fait
problématique de la mise à jour des
et quand on s'appelle mise à jour des
femmes des conditions d'utilisation et
ça que je me suis pas trop ans et demi
exactement après la seule chose que je
peux vous dire c'est que j'ai mis j'aime
me pencher dessus parce que
effectivement comme maintenant whatsapp
appartient à facebook et que je sais que
facebook y avait un petit peu mentir et
commission européenne en disant que
l'urée certaines choses qui ferait
jamais avec drake what's app
ça donne pas trop confiance j'ai entendu
parler des problèmes je crois de
confidentialité de whatsapp un de mes
amis a décidé de passer à signal je
crois à une autre application à cause de
ça mais autrement je les ai pas lu les
conditions d'utilisation je continue
parce que j'ai beaucoup d'amis ou de
relations professionnelles dessus en
fait mais j'avoue que je pense que je
passerai à autre chose dans les
prochains temps mais bon je pense déjà
que la vie privée déjà mort depuis un
moment maintenant c'est à dire y'a plus
de vie privée avril au vrai sens du
terme
déjà avec tous les réseaux sociaux tout
ça dans